欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这节课我们来讲一个非常重要的板块,就是违规处罚的一些规则
我们只讲一些比较重要而且常见的一些违规的类型和我们怎么样去规避
这样有利于我们在后期运营的过程中降低店铺运营的风险
因为如果你被处罚了可能被扣分
扣分了店铺就降权,降权的流量就变少了
或者是说你扣分的太多了
那么就有可能没有条件去报名一些活动
没有流量活动那么你的总的流量就少
另外一个可能扣分太多
那么整个店铺可能就被清电关闭了
那么这个是非常严重的损失的
所以一定要提前做好这些规避动作
首先第一个就是清权扣分
这个一定要重视
这里清权扣分的话可能是风格款式清权
可能是品牌池清权
可能是外观清权
可能是仿品清权
这些各种各样的都会有出现
常见的就是持清权跟风格
跟外观设计清权
这三类是常见的
你按照这种规则去做就可以了
第二个就是逾期发货扣分
因为你没有按照标准去发货
不符合平台规则被扣分了
每一个订单都会被扣一分
那么你的整的逾期率
就会提升, 逾期率提升的话
那么你的新等级就会有可能直接变成零星了
也就是你可能是五星或四星
只要你这个逾期发货被扣分
你的某一个指标不达标
那么你可能就是零星了
所以说一定要去重视这个板块
第三个就是投诉
还有TRO这种侵权
这种情况的话很有可能就是
店铺里面的所有的钱都被冻结
或者是说你的所有的店铺都会被
下架需要你重新一个一个手动的去上架
这都是非常严重的
TRO就是美国的一个禁令的一个侵权
如果是你被这个机构
或者被这个美国佬投诉了之后
那么你的整个店铺里面的钱都会被冻结
我们需要花钱去找律师和解
才能把店铺里面的交易额释放出来
不然这些钱会一直被冻结
接下来我们看一下它的扣分处罚方式
第一个就是如果扣到六分的时候
它会严重挺高
会邮件的通知我们
如果你扣到十二分就会现全七天
邮件通知我们系统处罚
现全什么是现全呢
也就是你的店铺流量可能分配降低产品的权重
店铺的权重都在下降
那么你总的流量就会在下降
很有可能你之前可能一万曝光量
现在可能只给你两千曝光量
接下来如果是你扣到二十四分
那么你会限全十四天
这两个基本都是屏蔽你的店铺了
屏蔽的天数是七天
这里是十四天
而且还会降全
所以说处罚非常的严重
你一定要去了解这些规则
然后规避这些风险
三十六分的话就会限制
全限二十一天
全店商品全部下降
就这种情况
四十八分直接关闭账号了
所以说这些你一定要
提前去了解去规避
严重侵权的话
这个也是经常有的
严重侵权它不扣分
但是它会屏蔽店铺
以及会给你的店户降权
同时呢
你这个店铺一整年内都无法参加活动
失去了活动流量
所以说
这是非常严重的一种侵权的行为
一定要注意这个
这个特别严重
所有的关于侵权的就讲完
我们来后台看一下
具体的一些内容
因为我们是没办法去一个个详细详解的
那么你需要的就是我们从服务中心这里到这个规则频道
跟这个违规投诉这里
自己去学习
自己去看
平时遇到的一些问题就在这里看
这里查询
多了解一下
基本的规则就可以了
也可以在这里搜
所以说这些东西我们没办法一个个去详解
只能靠自己不断的去看一些常见的就可以了
也没有必要
所有的看只需要看一些常规的就可以了
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见